today we're gonna be looking at SCP 3513
object class safe special containment
procedures the concrete bunker built
around SCP 3513 is to be guarded and
maintained by four permanent staff
maintaining the cover story of a water
pumping station undercover Foundation
agents are to be placed in all Namibian
hospitals to cover a pathological
reports suggesting the influence of SCP
35:13 any atypical increase in clinical
rates of degenerative brain disease in a
highly localized area is to be
investigated as a potential further
instance of scp-1305 no grafts to detect
potential anomalies in the Earth's outer
core are currently under consideration
description SCP 3513 as a region of
space located in rocky crest win Houk
namibia it is approximately cylindrical
in shape with a diameter of 3.4 meters
and a height above ground of two point
three meters evacuations have revealed
that SCP 35:13 extends below the ground
for at least 10 metres but its total
depth has not been measured any organism
with a brain that passes through SCP
35:13 will become subject to an
anomalous neurodegenerative disease the
disease will develop over a period of
four to six months with the following
progression a hard keratin nub develops
in the cerebrum the keratinized area
grows in proportion to the overall size
of the brain in humans it becomes
approximately five centimeters across
the tip of the keratin nub opens forming
a beak the interior of the biggest
coated and pointed keratin papillae over
a period of months
the beak slowly ingests brain tissue
consuming it but the pill I assist in
ensuring that the soft brain matter does
not slip out of the beak once it enters
the brain tissue consumed by the beak
disappears from the patient's brain
testing indicates that the interior of
the beak leads to an interdimensional
portal to another location or locations
the external symptoms of the SCP 35:13
disease depend largely on where in the
brain the keratin up initially forms but
it may be misdiagnosed as Krauts felled
Jakob Huntington's Parkinson's or
Alzheimer's disease confirmation of the
effects of SCP 3513 is only possible
through MRI or CT scan open neurosurgery
or autopsy foundation autopsies have
confirmed that following the death of
the patient
the beak continues to ingest any
remaining brain tissue tests locked
procedure 60 class were exposed to SCP
3513 and regular CT scans performed to
track the progression of the disease
upon the opening of the beak foundation
medical staff performed conventional
open neuro surgery on the relevant
d-class the use of human test subjects
was approved based on the requirements
for brain size and the ease of
anesthesia during the surgery
unnecessary brain tissue was removed to
allow access to the big a microscopic
surgical camera fitted with a GPS
tracking chip was fed slowly into the
beak and the results recorded and
analyzed exploration 35:13 - one subject
D 2879
results inside the SCP 35:13 beak the
camera filmed a passage lined with
papillae the camera was fed into this
passage for a distance of 1.4 meters the
GPS tracker was not able to be located
at this time D 2879 reported no
discomfort after the camera
progressed approximately 0.8 meters the
passage ended and the camera merged into
a dark hemispherical space a number of
openings were observed at intervals
around the sides of this space after
consultation
the surgical team proceeded to feed in
the camera filament allowing the camera
to enter into the opening of the
opposite wall of the space the opening
led to another passage lined with
papillae
although the observers noted that the
direction of the papillae was reversed
at 1.4 meters the camera emerged from
the interior of another carrot and beak
into what appeared to be further brain
tissue at this point a GPS signal was
obtained registering the cameras
location in Reedsburg Wisconsin after a
short delay the GPS signal became mobile
local foundation assets followed the
signal to Reedsburg Area Medical Center
where it was tracked to a recently
deceased patient norman miller
mr. miller had suffered a stroke
presumed to be caused by the sudden
appearance of the camera within his
brain the camera was retracted through
the beacon mr. Miller's brain back
through the passages and the beacon D
2879 s brain and D 2879 was returned to
monitoring without complications from
surgery exploration 35 13-2 subject D
43:53 results the camera filmed a
passage line with papillae for
approximately 0.7 meters entering a
similar hemispherical space to that
observed in exploration 35 13-1 and
being fed into an opening opposite its
point of entry
after progress down a second passage for
a further 0.8 meters the camera emerged
from a second beak and filmed
unidentified tissue which appeared to be
in motion this movement continued for
eight seconds before the camera
malfunctioned and lost picture the
camera was withdrawn from
passages and found to have been crushed
the GPS signal from the camera was
traced to a location outside Naples
Italy
further investigation revealed that the
coordinates belonged to a Cremona knee
meat processing plant a later biopsy of
D 4353 revealed trace amounts of
processed meat within his brain transfer
of meat into D 43:53 s brain is thought
to have occurred during the recovery of
the camera from its alternate location
which appears to have allowed material
from that location to travel back along
with the camera exploration 35 13-3
subject D 39:56
results after the camera had progressed
approximately 0.6 meters it emerged into
the hemispherical space an accidental
miss feeding of the film and resulted in
a change in the camera's alignment
within this space with the counter
facing downwards towards a wider opening
at the base of the chamber the camera
was fed into this opening filming the
papilla line passage which extended for
more than 2.5 meters no reversal of
papillae was observed and the passage
was observed to grow wider as it
continued after progressing for
approximately 3 meters the camera feed
suddenly cut out no GPS signal was
located upon retrieving the camera
filming attending medical staff noted
that the camera was missing and that the
end of the film had appeared to have
melted 5 seconds later a high pressure
jet of molten metal began to spray from
the incision in D 39:56 brain D 39:56 in
all attending medical personnel were
killed following reekin tainment of the
laboratory analysis confirmed that the
presence of several hundred kilograms of
iron nickel alloy initial temperature of
the molten metal is estimated to be up
to four thousand degrees kelvin testing
discontinued
this has been SCP 35:13